l'intelligence artificielle
c'est quelque chose de fascinant
on entend énormément de projets qui
bouleverse la société à l'heure actuelle
on peut citer les voitures autonomes qui
révolutionnent la façon dont on se
déplace qui permettrait de réduire
drastiquement le nombre d'accidents de
la route
on peut aussi mentionner la détection de
tumeurs de cancer dans l'imagerie
médicale
ce qui est beaucoup les médecins à faire
un diagnostic plus rapide plus précis on
entend aussi parler de ce sujet un petit
peu plus obscurs inquiétant
l'utilisation de la reconnaissance
faciale en chine à des fins politiques
par exemple
tous ces projets pose beaucoup de
questions il y en a une qui est très
importante
à quel point est ce que l'intelligence
artificielle peut imiter voire dépasser
le comportement et le raisonnement
humain avec quelques amis on s'est
penché sur cette question au travers de
quelque chose de fondamentalement humain
l'art la machine peut-elle créer de
l'art c'est comme ça qu'est née nos
artistes
un collectif qui est né en 2018 qui
génère de l'art avec de l'intelligence
artificielle
alors vous vous demandez probablement à
quoi ça ressemble quels résultats
peut-on obtenir en générant de l'art
avec les dernières technologies
je peux vous montrer deux exemples sur
les thèmes qu'on a travaillé le portrait
et le paysagement c'est ce genre de
résultat convoi qui parfois mark eaton
qui fait se poser la question est ce
qu'un humain aurait pu faire ça est-ce
qu à l inverse ce que la machine produit
est assimilable à un travail fait par un
humain la communauté artistique
s'intéressent beaucoup à ce sujet en ce
moment en 2018 il ya une vente de la
première oeuvre générés par intelligence
artificielle pour près d'un demi million
de dollars
il ya une norme énormément
ba qui ont suivi sa est ce que la
machine peut être faire preuve de
créativité
alors avant de répondre à cette question
il est intéressant de se pencher sur
quelque chose de préliminaires qu'est ce
que la créativité
qu'est ce qu'on met derrière cette
notion de création
si on regarde un petit peu avec un point
de vue scientifique ce regard des
papiers de neurosciences de sciences
cognitives les grands principes qu'on
peut dégager son que la créativité
repose sur un équilibre entre nouveaux
et déjà vu entre innovation qui choque
qui surprend et codes repères quelque
chose qui nous est famille
un exemple qui illustre particulièrement
bien ce raisonnement c'est le cubisme en
1937 pablo picasso peint guernica tout
ce qu'ils ont fait et espagnoles en
quatrième ronde et voir ce tableau c'est
un exemple phare du cubisme du cubisme
où on voit que la représentation de
l'objet est complètement repensé on va
pas essayer de regarder avec un seul
point de vue on va essayer de
représenter tous les points de vues
ensemble pour essayer d'aller chercher
l'essence de ce qu'on cherche à
représenter
on a donc une innovation dans le jeu de
formes de couleurs
mais tout ceci s'accompagne aussi d'un
certain nombre de codes on reconnaît
c'est de l'art figuratif on voit on
distingue des humains des animaux des
objets est encore plus important il y à
la présence d'un message en 1937 il ya
un contexte de guerre civile en espagne
extrêmement fort et ce tableau dénonce
la froideur et l'horreur de la guerre la
créativité
c'est un mélange un équilibre subtil
entre nouveaux et déjà vu
alors maintenant comment est ce qu'on
peut faire comment est ce qu'on peut
faire pour avec la machine modéliser ce
genre de raisonnement
comment est ce qu'on peut faire pour
essayer de pousser la machine à créer
quelque chose en 2014
yann goodfellow qui à cette époque
chercheur à stanford propose un
algorithme vous me pardonnerez l'accent
générative adversaire yole networks en
français les réseaux antagonistes
génératif depuis cet algorithme a été
repris de beaucoup de façons décliné par
de nombreux chercheurs également mais
voici les fondements principaux on va
avoir deux modules un module qui sera
assimilée à un apprenti peintre quelque
chose qui va générer ils nouvelle créer
quelque chose de nouveau et de l'autre
côté un module qui va s'efforcer de
rappeler les repères les codes on peut
l'assimiler à un critique d'art alors si
on rentre un peu plus concrètement dans
l'algorithme de façon séquentielle
comment est ce qu'on fait on va tout
d'abord rassemblé un certain nombre
d'image sur un thème on peut prendre par
exemple portrait le dessin de portraits
une fois qu'on aura rassemblé un certain
nombre d'image on va demander à notre
apprenti peintre de générer quelque
chose alors au départ il ya aucune idée
de ce vers quoi il va attendre donc ça
va ressembler à quelque chose de
complètement aléatoire un écran de
télévision qui ne marche pas ensuite on
va envoyer ses créations aux critiques
d'art le critique d'art il va prendre en
compte toutes les créations qu'ils ont
en effet il va attribuer des notes
ces notes elles sont établies en
comparant en comparant avec l'ensemble
des oeuvres d'art qu'on avait rassemblé
auparavant l'ensemble des portraits
qu'on avait rassemblé une fois ces notes
attribuées
on les renvoie à l'apprenti peintre qui
va prendre en compte le retour fait par
note de notre critique d'art
on va redemander ensuite à l'apprenti
peintre d'euros généré quelque chose de
renvoyer ses créations aux critiques
d'art qui va les noter et ainsi de suite
on ans on entre dans un processus
itératif ou au fur et à mesure
l'apprenti peintre va améliorer ses
créations donc si on regarde un peu
l'évolution des créations de l'apprenti
peintre d'abord quelque chose de
complètement aléatoire puis au fur et à
mesure on voit une forme ovale se
dessiner puis parfois des oreilles des
yeux une bouche au début incohérent et
puis le tout au fur et à mesure de façon
cohérente
on arrive donc à la fin avec un
algorithme qui est capable de générer
des portraits en reprenant les
caractéristiques présent dans l'ensemble
des portraits qu'on avait choisi au
départ à l'oreille une étape qui est
extrêmement importante on a donc un
algorithme qui est capable
théoriquement de produire une infinité
d'image et avec nos artistes
c'est à ce moment là qu'on va passer à
une étape de sélection
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
important c'est à ce moment là qu'on va
donner une identité à chaque image que
l'on sélectionne pour faire basculer du
monde digital dans le monde physique
dans le monde réel des créations d'un
algorithme deviennent des oeuvres d'art
du fait de l'intervention d'un humain on
peut prendre un exemple
autoportrait cette oeuvre donc a été
générés par un algorithme qui était
entraînée sur un certain nombre de
descentes portrait et on l'a nommé
autoportrait en référence aux à la
ressemblance qu'on trouve frappante avec
le travail de hegel schyle qui est un
peintre expressionniste autrichien
quand on met les deux côte à côte on
voit qu'on a les mêmes traits qui se
dégage quelque chose de creuser qui
parfois dérange est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement intéressant de noter il
n'y avait pas de peintres
expressionnistes dans l'ensemble des
portraits qu'on avait rassemblé au
départ donc c'est à dire que la machine
a su extrapolés pour reprendre à la fois
les codes d'un visage humain mais en
important quelque chose de nouveau
du fait de cette introduction
continuelle d'aléatoire au fur et à
mesure
du processus alors quand on dit que la
machine créée dollar oui mais attention
l'humain est intervenu à différentes
reprises dans le processus
on est intervenu au moment de créer le
dataset l'ensemble des images que l'on
va donner à disposition du critique
d'art
on est intervenu aussi au moment de
quelle algorithmes nous allons utiliser
que ce soit l'algorithme initial qui a
été inventé par ian wood feo ou d'une
déclinaison utile en utilisant
différentes implémentations et enfin
l'étape très importante où il ya une
véritable démarche artistique
la sélection qui donne une identité à
chaque oeuvre qui est sélectionné il est
donc possible de générer de l'art avec
de l'intelligence artificielle avec
l'aide de l'humain l'intelligence
artificielle tout seul c'est un outil
c'est quelque chose qui est très
classique dans l'inconscient collectif
de projeter la nature humaine sur ce qui
nous entoure les grecs le faisait par
exemple avec le dieu poséidon la mer les
intempéries l'océan que les choses qu'on
ne comprenait pas on va à simuler une
figure humaine personnifier le dieu grec
poséidon ont fait aujourd'hui la même
chose avec l'intelligence artificielle
rien que le nom intelligence la machine
n'a pas une intelligence dans le sens
humain du terme la machine n'a pas de
conscience
quand on lui demande de générer des
oeuvres d'art la machine n'a aucune
notion de qu'est ce que c'est que l'art
gagnent le cain qui est le lauréat du un
des lauréats du prix turing 2019 ce qui
est l'équivalent du prix nobel en
informatique exprime bien le sentiment
de la communauté scientifique sur le
sujet il dit que l'intelligence
artificielle
aujourd'hui est moins intelligentes
qu'un rat elle n'a pas de notion de bon
sens une intelligence artificielle ne
verrait pas de problème avec ces images
elle n'aurait livré aucune incohérence
pour cette magnifique créature
une intelligence artificielle tant
qu'elle n'a pas été entraînés à faire
quelque chose elle ne le fera pas elle
n'a pas cette capacité d'adaptation car
un être humain le scénario à la
terminator la matrix tout le fantasme
qu'on a véhiculé au travers de
différents films autour de la robotique
et l'intelligence artificielle n'a pas
de raison d'être
l'intelligence artificielle est un outil
certes qu'on ne maîtrise pas encore
totalement qu'on n'arrive pas forcément
a toujours expliqué à 100% mais ça reste
un outil dans les mains d'un humain
demain nous allons devoir prendre des
décisions autour de l'intelligence
artificielle que ce soit sur le plan
éthique légal voire même morale ces
décisions
elles ne seront prises de la bonne façon
que si les gens sont informés et ce en
quoi nous croyons avec nos artistes
on peut faire de l'art avec de
l'intelligence artificielle mais
l'intelligence artificielle n'est pas
une grande puissance toute puissante
création qui résout tous les problèmes
c'est un outil qui peut être utilisé à
bonne ou mauvaise escient merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]